my name is Steve Wasserman I'm editor of
the Los Angeles Times Book Review and it
is my privilege to welcome not only all
1,800 of you who are here in this
beautiful art deco theater The Wiltern
here in Los Angeles but also the many
tens of thousands perhaps hundreds of
thousands of others who will be watching
this broadcast live nationally on c-span
we are also being recorded by KCRW 89.9
FM here in los angeles by radio nation
as well which will broadcast the entire
proceedings at their network all over
the country as well the Los Angeles
Times the Los Angeles Institute for the
Humanities and the UC Berkeley Graduate
School of Journalism are the principal
sponsors of this event there is a long
list of co-sponsors which I do want to
acknowledge a kind of coalition of the
concerned who believe that sound by
debate can never replace a more fulsome
debate which we feel it is our
obligation both singly and collectively
to undertake at a moment of tremendous
national indeed international importance
before I welcome Dean Orville Schell of
the UC Berkeley Graduate School of
Journalism for a few welcoming remarks
let me just read in alphabetical order
and I please bear with me
the list of co-sponsors both individuals
and periodicals organizations and the
like who have helped make this event
possible the Atlantic Monthly the
Commonwealth Club of California the Los
Angeles County Art Museum's Institute
for art and cultures the Los Angeles
Public Library the LA Weekly the Los
Angeles world affairs council the nation
radio nation the New York Institute for
the Humanities the New York Review of
Books the Norman Lear Center at USC
Annenberg School Occidental College Open
Society Institute Penn USA The Reason
Foundation Betty and Stanley Sheinbaum
Barbra Streisand town hall Los Angeles
the UCLA International Institute and the
USC Annenberg School for Communication
thank you
let me introduce for a few welcoming
remarks Dean Orville Schell well thanks
Steve
it's very gratifying to see you all here
on this eve of I think some
unprecedented events and I suspect I
know why most of you are here you could
be home in your families at a movie
having dinner but I think it's this
sense that the country is heading into
some very uncharted waters waters and
that in fact we really have not had a
chance to have the kind of discussion
that might have led to a more hopeful
end to what I think could be a quite
tragic scenario I think this that there
is a kind of a food chain of events that
has to happen in order for those kinds
of discussions to have real effect
starts with an issue it goes to the
media gets factored into the public and
ultimately back to the media and up to
those who formulate policy and I think
this is really what has been missing
those synapses have not been firing
correctly and I think many of you like
like me have probably a little weary of
hearing people yell at each other on
television so this debate is a provides
a a more formal structure as Steve said
and it's it's the kind of event that I
think we ought to have more of
particularly on the media it's the
second debate we had one up at the
University of California Berkeley with
Mark Danner and Christopher Hitchens and
Steve came up and thought this is a
great idea indeed it is and I very much
hope that this will be one of many of
these debates that we can have here in
the West Coast with these conferees of
organizations and the Los Angeles Times
so Steve thanks for taking this on
without further ado let me bring out our
panelists I'll make a few opening
remarks and then we will begin a
conversation which it is hope will shed
at least as much light as heat
because we're also being broadcast by
radio it will be important for all of us
from time to time to exercise the most
stringent discipline and insofar as
we're humanly capable of not interrupt
each other even though every fiber in
our bodies may desire it so that the
listening audience can actually know who
is spoke speaking and I will from time
to time reintroduce the panelists as as
as the occasion warrants
let us first say that this last period
year and a half or so has been I'm
almost tempted to say unprecedented
certainly in my lifetime a degree of
bellicosity a degree of rhetorical
flourish has inflamed the language both
of policy and ordinary talk many
Americans like many people all over the
world have grouped themselves around
dinner tables and breakfast tables and
water coolers and on street corners to
debate what feels at least to some
critics like what people might have felt
in 1913 we appear at least to some to be
on the precipice of a potential great
catastrophe for others we seem finally
to be on the eve of an epoch of
emancipation we are plunged into this
moment by the fact that there has been
assembled in Mesopotamia a tremendous
military machine which has girdled a
state called Iraq which is a kind of
synthetic but real country formed in
1920 through 24 carved out of lines in
the sand which has endured decades of a
very difficult and troubled history
whether or not the Bush administration's
desire to both topple Saddam Hussein and
disarmed his country is both justified
and wise is the point of departure for
tonight's discussion and debate it is
our hope that in the two hours that we
have this evening that we will challenge
received opinion that we will remark
upon some of the shibboleths and canards
that have affected and deformed much of
what has passed for debate that we will
try to explore some of the ironies and
paradoxes that have for many people
exploded old categories of what has
heretofore been thought to be the left
position or the right position we seek
to find the right position the moral
position a position consistent with what
we understand to be the Republic's
interests and indeed the interests of
securing peace with justice for peoples
all over the world including our own let
us begin
and I will introduce each of the
speakers in turn and for the first
period they will each have about 12
minutes in television land 12 minutes
might seem an eternity and particularly
with no break for commercial but it
seems to us in the short attention span
culture that Corson's almost all debate
that this gives us at least and each of
the speakers a bit of elbow room to
stretch out with the notion and to plumb
it in some way we of course will not be
able in this evening to address all
issues that have attached themselves to
the principle one before us like so much
collateral damage but we hope at least
to raise the kinds of questions that all
of you can begin to think about and with
any luck may challenge the sorts of
notions that you entered this hall with
this evening to begin we will begin with
Christopher Hitchens a Christopher
Hitchens is
currently the if' stonefellow at the UC
Berkeley Graduate School of Journalism
he is as many of you may know the
contributing editor a contributing
editor to Vanity Fair
he's the author of numerous books
including most recently why Orwell
matters it is a matter of I think almost
in arguable ascent that he is one of the
most gifted whether one agrees with him
or not
polemicists of his generation
Christopher Hitchens
thank you Steve for very handsome
introduction thanks also to your
suspiciously long list of sponsors seems
almost consensual the way phrase do and
to the LA Times in the LA Weekly
particularly for their energy in this
and I'd like also in a Fraternal spirit
to offer my opening thanks also to the
anti-war movement for so bravely
I hope these I hope that wonderful
applause doesn't come out of my time the
anti woman for so that I will movement
for so bravely and doggedly and
stubbornly wearing and displaying the
medals of its defeats it takes a certain
amount of moral courage I think to do
that or courage of a sort I don't just
mean that the defeat they suffered over
Bosnia or Afghanistan or Kosovo I don't
have to rub in the fact that if their
advice had be listened to Kuwait would
now be the 19th province of Iraq and
would have been for some years Bosnia
would be part of greatest Serbia Kosovo
would be a howling wilderness dominated
by the ideology of ethnic cleansing and
Afghanistan would still be run by the
Taliban
that's what you would have got if you'd
heard the anti-war movements arguments
and taking them seriously before and in
many cases including those who run this
movement actually organized it that
would have been the desired result I'd
speak rather tonight I think to the
people for whom that result would at
least be unintentional those who have
the excuse of innocence I suppose I mean
the touching way in which they now call
for more containment more sanctions and
more inspections in other words they can
see that every step of this policy so
far and all the success that it has had
hard-won and bitterly fought is
self-evidently attributable to the
program put forward by those of us who
have long favoured regime change in Iraq
there would be no sanctions inspections
containments or no-fly zones if it
wasn't for that
and while many people want to hold it
right there and say this far and no
further
there are some of us who've long
believed that the logical and moral
conclusion is to finish this task and
complete it and this will have the happy
result of the full emancipation of the
Iraqi and Kurdish peoples from a regime
of an explicitly National Socialist type
now I took this view long before George
Bush did and so if you want to bring up
Kyoto or capital punishment in Texas or
any other thing that may be on your mind
prescription drugs for seniors I don't
know
save it would you we're discussing Iraq
tonight want to hear another really
stupid argument there are some people
some of them with actual Jewish names
who've been wanting to remove Saddam
Hussein for some time I have to break
this to you someone has to tell you
they've had it in for him for a
considerable period Bush himself is only
a very recent convert to this to this
scheme I've been in Washington for 21
years ladies and gentlemen comrades and
friends brothers and sisters let me tell
you what I've learned the Gentiles keep
worming their way into high positions no
matter what you do it's worse than you
might think actually Paul Wolfowitz
wrote the first essay warning that
Saddam Hussein was an aggressive tyrant
who hoped to romp donate the Gulf he
wrote in 1978 that's almost a quarter
century of being essentially right I ask
you what could possibly be more sinister
than that now I'm quite happy to give my
support to this open conspiracy I joined
it more recently than some but earlier
than others and very happy in fact proud
to say that my solidarity belongs with
the brave fighters of the Patriotic
Union of Kurdistan and the Iraqi
National Congress
some of you wouldn't know what courage
was unless you've seen what some of
these people have fought against and how
they've had to fight it I don't want to
be part of Saddam Hussein's human shield
constituency and every bit of the
progress that's been made so far has
come from the careful
graduated deployment of force or the
believable threat of it and every
betrayal along that road
particularly the 1991 decision of the
Bush administration to leave Saddam
Hussein in power and not just to leave
him in power but to stand by while he
used helicopter gunships to Massacre
again and humiliated gain and torture
again what I refused to call I declined
to call his own people but the the
people of Iraq who were slaves then and
will be free tomorrow this policy which
was dictated by the regime of Saudi
Arabia that didn't want regime change in
its region and still doesn't and for
very good reasons and didn't want the
emancipation of the Shia Muslims those
were the consequences of diplomacy
secret diplomacy sometimes open
otherwise and of compromise if I could
see you or which I can't because the
lights remise I would ask you to put up
your hands if you favor any of you the
removal of the no-fly zones that have
for the past dozen years or so protected
the people of kurdistan and of southern
Iraq
perhaps I could I could sense a rustle
if many hands went up nobody wants to do
that well then we've been at war with
Saddam Hussein for some time haven't we
and we are at war with him now and the
argument about what side to be on and
how to prosecute this matter has
essentially been already decided and in
a wonderful way in my view on the side
of principle we have demonstrated in the
northern sixth of Iraq the area that's
roughly contiguous with with Kurdistan
we've already demonstrated that regime
change is no utopia already in that part
of Iraq emancipated from the rule of a
sadistic megalomaniac there are there's
a party system there are 21 newspapers
there are three female high court judges
their internet cafes and the oil
revenues was this areas under sanctions
to scarce as they are spent on the
reconstruction of the country's roads
and schools and hospitals and not on the
upkeep of a parasitic and aggressive
military oligarchy it's already been
proved and by the way this gain this
enormous gain from the interventionist
regime change policy may have to be
defended not just against Iraq but also
against Turkey in which case
those of us who favor regime change are
obliged to say as I do that we would be
on their side still and it would be a
good slogan for the peace movement I
think to demand down with Turkish
unilateralism
in Iraq but somehow they can't seem to
must have that kind of energy now I
don't have to go all the way back to 91
excuse me all the way back to 78 where
per Wolfowitz began the struggle just
take it to 1989 finally it seemed to
most of us that the the discredited
bankrupt sinister idea of the one-party
state the one-party regime had been
finally banished in an enormous shout of
liberation those regimes collapsed on
one end of Europe to another and one of
the great moments of human emancipation
was consummated we look forward then
some of us to a peace dividend some of
you will cast your minds back that far
we thought that perhaps a new era in
international relations and internal
affairs was dawning but we've been
cheated of this and we're at this grave
hour now because of the survivors of the
ridiculous idea of the worshiped one man
one rule one party regime Saddam Hussein
invaded Kuwait sabado Milosevic tried to
create a greater Serbia Kim Jong Il even
as no South Korea was evolving under the
heroic in my opinion campaign leadership
of Kim dae-jung
into something like a functioning
democracy was using this time to become
an international plutonium merchant and
now these people have been joined in
what I would call a sort of Hitler style
impact or an even more hideous faction
those who believe not just in the one
party but in the one God and the jihad
and that's how we got Afghanistan and
that alliance now do you think or does
anybody believe that a confrontation
with this kind of system that is
inherently aggressive as well as
inherently pornographic and dictatorial
is postponed able is it not rather
inevitable that we will have to confront
these regimes and their intentions who
would let the other side pick the time
of this confrontation who would let them
preempt who would allow us a time was
saying to do as he's always done before
the time and place of the engagement
rather I think we should say no it's
enough we will pick we will pick the day
that your rule comes to an end
there used to be a slogan when the left
had good three word slogans that said
fascism means war what it meant by that
was the fascism intense war and desires
war and entails war it just means the
two questions are in dis audible and now
we hear no war on Iraq chanted by people
who say no quarrel with Saddam Hussein
and if they want more time as they now
bleep that they do what are they going
to use this time for what does time mean
in this context in May the UN Special
Committee on disarmament will start to
be chaired by Iraq shall we wait for
that would that be a good deadline want
to know who the co-chair is Iran what
shall we give them time for that why do
you think that Kim jong-il is now able
to talk to us as if he was the one with
deterrent power because Hans Blix was
the inspector in his case and asked to
give him more time and certified him as
strenuously attempting to comply with
the non-proliferation treaty and Saddam
Hussein wants time so he can join the
Kim Jong Il Club and I don't think he
could have it and I can't believe that
anyone in this room think so either
Thank You Christopher Oh
when it was a started I'd like to
introduce mark Danner his professor at
UC Berkeley's Graduate School of
Journalism I suspect he is down the hall
from Christopher this semester and they
passed an unruly collegiality in that
hall mark Danner is also a staff writer
for The New Yorker he's the author of a
remarkable piece of investigative
reportage published some years ago about
the depredations in Central America and
titled the massacre at el mozote a
professor dinner thank you Steve and
thank all of you it is wonderful to join
a crusade Christopher has just
introduced you to the power and the
passion that you can feel in the thought
of fighting for the right what better
thing than to go off and destroy evil
what better thing than to search out
monsters and destroy them and Saddam
Hussein is indeed terribly evil he is a
horrible dictator he has done atrocious
things so who could quarrel with this
who could quarrel with the case that
Christopher just made surely no one
we're all on the side of the right and
yet as we speak
the President of the United States finds
himself floating on an island in the
middle of the Atlantic with no one to
play with but Tony Blair and Jose Marie
Osmond
now why is this surely it's because of
the duplicity of the French surely it's
because the rest of the world is simply
wrong why is it that not only the French
but the Russians the Chinese the Germans
four of the half-dozen most powerful
countries of the world not to mention as
we've seen over the last week the
ghanaians the Cameroonians the Angolans
the mexicans the Chileans the Pakistanis
the Turks find this a terrible idea so
terrible that the Turks seem to have
turned down six billion or thirteen
billion or 40 billion dollars depending
on whom you're talking to
what makes these countries so stupid why
do they think this battle for the right
is such a terrible idea now we can say
they're duplicitous or we can say
Jacques Chirac is a pimp or we can say
Hans Blix is a disaster we can ascribe
this to a lot of reasons but we have to
as we stand here tonight on the brink of
war and war will begin in a matter of
days as we stand here tonight on the
brink of war it would be wonderfully
welcomed I think if we could come up
together with the reason why the United
States will very soon attack invade and
occupy Iraq Christopher has given you a
set of reasons the man's evil the man's
evil we have to destroy regimes like his
first come Saddam then perhaps Kim
jong-il maybe after that Robert Mugabe
and we could go on in a long list the
fact is the Iraq crisis which is in the
title of our two
eight tonight what exactly is that
crisis I would put to you the crisis has
to do with the last few months of
diplomacy in which the United States has
succeeded in isolating itself from its
closest allies from the rest of the
world and even from states that it has
been habituated to purchase in
diplomatic support very few people are
with the United States why I would
venture to say that the United States is
virtually alone in its public definition
of the threat that Iraq poses I would
venture to say that the United States in
the last six months has closed the
policy of regime change in a policy of
disarmament and that many nations
including those in the security
council's have concluded reasonably that
if what the goal is is actually to
disarm Iraq to render it impotent then
this indeed can be done it can be
achieved and that further the United
States is intent on war because it does
not have in its mind the idea of
disarming Iraq it wants to remove Saddam
Hussein it wants to fight what might be
called a war of convenience against a
state that does not directly threaten it
and occupy that state and redefine the
international order in the Middle East
these are imperial dreams you are being
asked to sign on through an argument
based first of all on a moral crusade
which Christopher Hitchens is very Abele
and very eloquently set out in front of
you and a regimen of fear it is no
accident that half of the American
people currently believe that Saddam
Hussein was behind the attacks of 9/11
that's no accident
the administration has defined Iraq as a
struggle against fear and against threat
and yet what we have we found out in the
last six months we have found out first
that Iraq does not have
a nuclear program mr. ElBaradei has seen
to that it was destroyed by the
inspectors in the nineteen excuse me by
the inspectors and others in the 1990s
there is no nuclear program and many of
you may have noticed that the
administration has stopped talking about
the nuclear program so what is the
threat that Iraq poses it has no doubt
some chemical weapons it has no doubt
some perhaps biological weapons indeed
it had those in the 1980s when we were
allied with Iraq perhaps we should look
at the bill of attainder against Iraq
that the administration has put forward
repeatedly he attacks his neighbor's he
gasses his own people we've heard that
again and again it's fascinating we're
talking about an attack on his neighbor
first Iran in 1980 that was supported
first by the carter administration and
then by the reagan administration it was
in our national interests and there was
nothing erratic about it the Americans
knew it was coming they supported it
during the war they armed the Iraqis
they floated the economy with three
billion dollars in agricultural credits
they armed Iraq's army with shipments
through our Egyptian and Saudi allies
and finally and here we get to gassing
his own people they supplied through our
intelligence agencies targeting
information for use of Iraq's gas
weapons now you might say well you know
this was long ago does a dozen years ago
or more
those same officials are in office today
those distant officials Paul Wolfowitz
Paul Wolfowitz Richard Perle : Powell
Donald Rumsfeld the great envoi to
Baghdad Reagan's envoi visited him twice
Saddam Hussein bringing letters of peace
now you might say well goodness that
they got it wrong 14 15 years ago that
doesn't mean we can't get it right now
but I would make two remarks on that
first it should cause you to cast doubt
on the arguments about the threat the
Iraqi dictator poses to the United
States about his erratic character
secondly it should cause you to doubt
the general arguments you're hearing if
indeed these officials are essentially
pointing to the graves of Kurds who were
gassed graves that they could have
prevented and they are looking out at
you and saying look at what this man has
done send your young men and women to
remove him
look how terrible he is when a dozen
years ago they gave him money they gave
him arms and they showed him where to
place his gas then I think you have to
ask yourself a question when you
consider these arguments are you
citizens or are you dupes
and after you ask yourself this question
you should look a little bit at the
record the more recent record you should
look at Bob Woodward's book in which
four days after 9/11 we hear in meetings
at Camp David Paul Wolfowitz should they
think about launching military action
elsewhere as an insurance policy in case
things in Afghanistan went bad
that's a quote attacking Afghan
Afghanistan would be uncertain in
contrast Iraq was a brittle oppressive
regime that might break easily the US
would have to go after Saddam at some
point and then Don Rumsfeld the
erstwhile envoi to Baghdad is this the
time to attack Iraq he noted that this
would be a big buildup of forces in the
region and he was still deeply worried
about the availability of good targets
in Afghanistan now I'm not sitting here
saying there's some plot I'm sitting
here saying that the idea that Iraq is a
vital threat to the United States is
ridiculous and countries around the
world countries around the world
including our closest allies recognize
this what we are here tonight debating
is what our future is going to be as a
nation how we're going to behave in the
world of nations how we're going to
behave with our allies and how we deal
with problems that can be dealt with not
through use of military force but
through diplomacy thank you Mark
I should now like to introduce Michael
Ignatieff who is the director of the
Carr Center for Human Rights policy at
Harvard University's JFK's Kennedy
School of Government he's also the
author of numerous books recently the
Warriors honor blood and belonging and a
marvelous biography of the late is aya
Berlin Michael Ignatieff I can't see you
but those of you who are undecided that
is those of you who are anguished by the
choices that you have to make as
citizens the choice is put to us are is
this justified and is this wise what is
justified may not be wise and so I want
to talk to those who are still in a mode
to make up your mind I wanted to ask
first of all are there alternatives to
war there certainly are alternatives to
war there's no war should never be
regarded as inevitable let's look at the
alternatives one alternative is to
strengthen inspections but the problem
with strengthening inspections is that
they're only credible if backed by force
and France Russia China have made it
clear that they will veto in at almost
any circumstances that is to say the
French proposition that we can avoid war
by continuous inspections depends for
its credibility on the very exercise of
force that they're prepared to veto and
this seems to me to be
this seems to me to be just a problem
with strengthened inspections we could
then decide that we should simply deter
Saddam and he I think he could be
deterred from using weapons of mass
destruction but as Mark Tanner has
conceded he does have some chemical and
biological weapons and what I think is
much more difficult to deter is the
possible transfer of these technologies
to al Qaeda and other terrorist groups
I think the process the possibility of
this happening is small but any
possibility north of zero does pose a
national security threat to the United
States we could also then consider
containment which would be maintaining
the no-fly zones maintaining sanctions
trying to lock the regime down so that
he can't use oil revenue to develop
weapons of mass destruction but as Chris
has pointed out sanctions have exerted a
very high cost on the Iraqi people the
no-fly zones involve combat operations
in a sense we've managed to prevent
Saddam from committing genocide against
the Kurdish people but the cost of
containment
are high and that those costs are
already being paid by the Iraqi people
and all of these options strengthen
expect inspections deterrence and
containment do leave 25 million people
in jail with a dictator that is a
consequence a cost of peace it's as
evident to me as it is to you that there
are serious costs to war I'm only asking
you to think seriously and hard about
the consequences of peace the
consequences of peace will be paid by
the Iraqi people now
Pease leaves Saddam possibly without a
nuclear program I concede that point
Marx made a good point there but it
leaves his strategic intentions entirely
unchanged
it seems to me nobody in this audience
would claim that this man does not have
the strategic and intention to possess
weapons of mass destruction there is an
empirical question as what he as to what
he possesses but there can't be any
doubt as to what his strategic
intentions are and we leave him in
possession of the country and we leave
him in possession of strategic
intentions which seemed to me to pose a
threat the fact that the world does not
support us is is deeply problematic mark
Danner has made a good point there but
propositions don't become wrong simply
because other people don't agree with
you propositions don't become right
let's do this symmetrically propositions
don't become right because everyone
agrees with you this is the burden that
we all have as citizens we have to
decide what propositions convinces the
fact that these propositions don't
convince the French doesn't frankly mean
very much to me okay now and I'm let me
make a cautious case for war having
looked at some of the alternatives the
case for war is as Chris suggested that
it frees the Iraqi people twenty-five
million people from a dictatorship it
allows them to create a federal
democratic Iraq free of weapons of mass
destruction it gives those people the
first chance in their in two generations
to take the money from oil and use it to
build roads and schools and hospitals as
opposed to chemical and biological
weapons it does eliminate the threat or
reduces sharply reduces the threat to
the State of Israel it reduces
the leadership of Arab rejection ISM the
part of the Arab world that says they
will never come to terms and live in
peace with the State of Israel ever it
subjects those forces to serious
historical defeat and finally it
eliminates the possibility a low
possibility but still a possibility of
weapons of mass destruction transfer to
al-qaeda what is the case against war
the case against war is a prudential
case and it's not a weak case I think
it's a strong case here I might even
disagree with Chris the case against war
is the people will die quite a lot of
people may die I am NOT one who thinks
that this is a 72-hour wonder we have
absolutely no way of being certain what
the human cost of this war will be the
cost may be high in American lives it
may be high in Iraqi lives there's no
point of an honest debate unless I
concede to you that I cannot tell you
that the cost will be zero I cannot tell
you that the cost will be low and it's
morally dishonest to pretend that we're
not talking about the death of human
beings here the second cost is the
possibility that this operation will
simply increase hatred for the United
States and instead of reducing risk to
the United States to you as citizens
increase the risk to citizens of the
United States to which I can only say
it's a fair point
to which I can only say this country is
deeply hated already it's not clear to
me this is gonna make it so much worse
but let me make but let me make another
point which seems to me
crucial here you can't
I think conceived an Iraq operation
which produces freedom for the Iraqi
people even under difficult
circumstances apart from what seems to
me integrally linked to it the absolute
strategic necessity of the Palestinian
people getting a state of their own I
say I say strategic I say strategic
necessity because the only long-term
guarantee of the security of the State
of Israel is a legitimate democratic and
stable state in Palestine for the
Palestinian people
what one of the policy ironies that
needs to be firmly understood is there
are no people in the middle-aged beast
who hate the Americans more than the
Palestinians there are no people in the
Middle East who need the Americans more
you need the Americans more than the
Palestinians because frankly the only
power capable or insisting as a
consequence of this operation that there
are two states in the Middle East is the
American government this is an irony
that needs to be firmly understood I
would find it difficult to support this
operation just on national security
grounds unless there's a linkage between
the two operations because it does seem
to me to increase the risks of the
United States if you have Tommy Franks
in Baghdad and helicopter gunships in
Khan Younis it seems to me the only way
we conceive this as acceptable ethically
is if the Palestinian people get a state
my sense is that the chances of that
happening are increased by an Iraqi
operation for two reasons one the
Americans can turn to the Israelis and
say listen we have removed your chief
strategic threat it's time for you to do
business we can then turn to the
Palestinians and say your chief champion
is out of here it's time to settle this
conflict in conclusion I support the
President on this issue I don't support
him on almost anything else
second secondly and finally because my
red light is on supporting the President
on this does not mean you think America
is the last best hope of mankind
it doesn't commit you to any set of
ideological propositions about this
country this country has done some great
things
mark Danner has shown the moments when
it's done some terrible things my
proposition to you is this might be a
case if it's done right in which
American power is allied with freedom
for 25 million people thank you we had
some technical problems for the next 10
minutes or so as we continue with
comments by syndicated columnist Robert
Scheer a little worried after marks
presentation that I wouldn't have
anything to say because it was so clear
a case against acting without the UN
Security Council at this time but I do
have a place to fill here which is that
of George W Bush whose views on the war
have not been presented at all George W
Bush did not tell us we had to go to war
with Iraq to make the world perfect or
to free all the people who live under
tyranny he was elected specifically in
opposition to that notion he was against
nation-building which he thought was
dangerous remember when Bill Clinton
sent cruise missiles in to take out al
Qaeda
it was the same conservatives that
condemned him for drawing attention from
the all-important affair Monica Lewinsky
and trying to wear the dog during the
first part of the Bush administration
was absolutely no interest in terrorism
Iraq tyranny human rights there was
interest in the drug war that was the
preoccupation and towards that end we
even had meetings with the Taliban
officials and while we asked them to do
something about our qaeda and maybe turn
them over our main emphasis was to
congratulate them on eliminating the
opium
the opium crop is back in force without
the Taliban so let me state what has
been the position of this administration
and it is important to state it because
after all we live in a democracy we're
trying to export this model to the world
and if our president cannot back up his
arguments and but more crudely if he has
lied to us and as Mark pointed out on
one of his biggest lies the connection
between Iraq and al Qaeda forty percent
of the people believe it what does this
say about the Free Press the free
society are very modeled how did people
come to believe something that the
administration cannot support the two
propositions driving our attention
towards Iraq was from the first
beginning days that Iraq was behind al
Qaeda behind the attack on the World
Trade Center let's not forget that this
was they said they had in the words of
Rumsfeld bullet proof evidence
now they have searched high and low I
can assure you the New York Times the
other day had a description of the
torture or near torture or neo torture I
guess is the right word that is used and
yet they have not come up with a single
shred of connection between the World
Trade Center and Saddam Hussein okay so
when the president said today in his
radio address one reason that we have to
go after this man is to remove a patron
and protector of terror I thought he was
talking about Saudi Arabia Kuwait the
oil and there's
for Pakistan where we know their Secret
Service was behind the Taliban and was
giving support to al-qaeda so this is
the big lie the big line is
loathsomeness Saddam Hussein maybe
certainly loves him and if we're going
to free all of the people who live under
loathsome dictators that's a tall order
there are quite a few that may be every
bit as not attractive or even more so
but that wasn't the argument of 'some in
astray ssin some argue administration
was at this country which was
traumatized by the terrorist attack on
the World Trade Center on the Pentagon
itself fourth that was an explanation
that this guy over there in Iraq this
evildoer this devil and so forth
he must be behind it and Rumsfeld said
even a year later bulletproof evidence
they don't have it it's amazing that
they haven't been able to plant it okay
it's number one
all right and it is very unfair in these
attacks on the French and the Germans
and the Chinese and the Russians to
pretend that they are don't care about
terrorism when they've all experienced
terror they've had the bombings in their
societies they know full well the cost
of empire but also they deserve major
credit for helping to crack al-qaeda we
know the French we know the Germans we
know the Russians we know the Chinese
have played a major role so make it to
seem like they're these you know people
just sitting on the sidelines who don't
care is utter nonsense and what they're
worried about is the distraction
secondly the argument before us is
whether we move now or we wait for four
months the Finks the pacifists the
marchers the French all of these
terrible people have said let's the
inspectors do their work let's wait for
months deport Chileans they tried to say
let's wait three weeks and that was
slapped down now why wait four months
okay the argument for waiting four
months is that these inspectors are
doing their work and in their own words
have in fact made a great deal of
progress it was conceded rather loosely
here on the main point and we talked
about in weapons of mass destruction
let's not kid ourselves the nuclear
weapons are the serious weapons of mass
destruction all right and on that main
point no one seems to defend the idea
that Iraq has made any progress since
1991 no one has come up with any
evidence in fact there's been fakery
deception but even on the other weapons
we know that the inspectors as Hunt's
book said they're not destroying
toothpicks to destroying lethal weapons
we made a big deal about the missiles
which by the way were revealed in their
document which we said was unimportant
and they are destroying those missiles
we said there was missiles were terribly
important now we say those missiles are
unimportant you know you can't have it
both ways
so the inspection this
our work now the only valid argument
because the inspections are making
progress to go now and not wait to four
months and have the unity of the
Security Council how the support by the
way it wasn't always so that the world
hated us throughout the Cavalier
admission here that somehow this
administration and in less than two
years or whatever it is has managed to
get the whole world to hate us it's not
unimportant we have to live in that
world this was the one world New World
Order that George Bush was bringing
about you know we have to we have to
live and and trade with these people
okay
the only argument for going now is if
you thought as George Bush has said
repeatedly repeatedly and repeatedly his
said there's an immediate threat of
these weapons of mass destruction or an
immediate threat that some of this
material would be turned over to
terrorists now come on if there's a
threat of this material being turn of
the service why wouldn't they come from
the people who support the terrorists
and whom the terrorists like because
they're good Muslims and not from this
socialist secular guy whom they hate
okay why wouldn't they come from
Pakistan why wouldn't they come from
Saudi Arabia why wouldn't they come why
would they come from the guy in
Washington who made anthrax who supposed
to have made it in American laboratory
according to the FBI why would they have
to come on this slim chance from Iraq
and if it is a slim chance that is the
basis for invading countries there are a
lot of other countries we could be
invading tomorrow okay so the argument
that there are weapons of mass
destruction is in fact the very thing
that the inspectors the immediate threat
has destroyed and I think the reason we
don't want the four months as the
administration will lose its main
argument for going to war with Iraq and
it will lose that argument with the
American public now let me just address
the human rights question because I
think it's important and I want to
straighten out one thing two things here
we didn't get involved with Iraq just 15
or 20 years ago but as roger maris
points out who was a former member the
NSC we got involved with Saddam Hussein
40 years ago and we put the boss party
in power and we supported said I'm
saying at every key moment okay and so
this idea that somehow we didn't know
about him no we helped create him just
as we helped create the Taliban remember
they were the Mujahideen that were
fighting the Communists but what is
important about what Mark was saying
about this evidence is that it's old you
see the justification for going now is
there's to be something new what's
happening the attack on the Kurds to use
the chemical weapons that stuff that
poor guy the English had this great
intelligence report based on a guy's
doctoral candidates research in Monterey
there was 11 12 years old based on
events that happened in the previous
decade the reason that's important is
because the President as he did today he
brought up the gassing of the curt's
terrible event no question about it but
it did happen 15 years ago what happened
then
today President Bush said this is the
15th anniversary of the chemical weapons
use the chemical attack just one of 40
targeted young people provides a glimpse
of the crimes that amla sane is willing
to commit the kind of 30 now presents
the entire world
he is among history's cruelest dictators
he's an arming himself with the world's
most terrible weapons based on something
that happened 15 years ago what did the
US under George Bush who was president
then do I quote the great Authority
William Safire from a column of November
23rd 1989 William Safire says how has
the United States government responded
to this continual rape of human rights
our Export Import Bank has provided a
200 million line of credit to Iraq our
Department of Agriculture has provided 1
billion in commodity credits to Saddam's
cash short regime our State Department
eager to woo Iraq turns a blind eye to
the suffering of the people being told
to assimilate or die that's how we
responded then under George Bush's
father to that chemical weapons attack
the same attack that is brought up now
15 years later to justify going to war
against Iraq was used to justify aid at
that time
I want to say a final thing about the
human rights concern there is no doubt
that you can make a case for intervening
the question is you trust the people who
are going to be doing the intervening no
no Imperial regime no Imperial regime
has ever failed to defend its actions in
noble terms of noble slogans when the
French went into Vietnam in Algeria it
was for civilization for Catholicism for
decency and the English went all over
the world that was certainly to raise
the standards of living you know
when we went into Vietnam this human
rights thing is not new remember not
just Vietnam Grenada why did we know in
a Grenada Human Rights concerned you
know the great threat you know where
grenadiers now is one of Cuba's closest
trading partners really care about
Grenada what happened when we lost in
Vietnam these people in jail
what happened Vietnam went to war with
Communist China totally unpredicted by
our policy now Vietnam in communist
China two countries which by the way in
the old days speakers would have argued
for intervening let's liberate them
let's free the people from jail they're
now seen as benign why because they're
bracing capitalism the fact is the
history of the post-war of the Cold War
period shows that containment works the
containment of communism worked the
could a trade works and what we are
doing is a terrible disservice to
democracy to saying we could fight a war
based on a lie in the name of Liberty it
doesn't wash Thank You mr. chair
we will now have a series of short
rebuttals and then we will have a kind
of seemly free-for-all mr. Hitchens
gentlemen thank you I don't know how
evident it is to all of you that you
just applauded rather easily I thought
am I not loud enough
I don't know how ever did it is to you
ladies and gentlemen then you just gave
a round of applause to Robert Scheer for
regretting that the gassing of the
Kurdish people had not been conducted
more recently he wants it to be he wants
no he wants it he says that old stuff
that also if we want the case we made
I've got a proof there's been more
recent gassing of the Kurds what a
scandalous state of affairs that you
should clap such a thing let me just say
to you why that hasn't happened why why
is the evidence old why is the evidence
old why is the evidence old because for
12 years and more pilots of the United
States Air Force and the Royal Air Force
of the United Kingdom have protected the
Kurds from exactly that faith that's why
Saddam Hussein hasn't done any genocide
recently you want fresher evidence give
him more time he'll sure provide it to
you but this is frivolous talk you know
do you think that Saddam Hussein lost
his nuclear capacity in 1991 because of
diplomacy was it a peace movement that
took it away from him no he lost a war
and he lost the ability for a while to
control his own country and it was to
the tremendous shock of the inspectors
and the UN that it was discovered how
near he'd got to a nuclear device at
that time and he has himself only ever
made one self-criticism that he should
have waited to get the bomb before he
invaded Kuwait that's the way the man
thinks now I don't know how many of you
imagine that North Korea is behaving in
this way now with this sudden aggressive
nuclear promiscuity in some way that is
wholly unconnected to developments in
the Middle East that it's just a
coincidence that Kim Jong Il is
providing this a distraction
from his ally and friend Saddam Hussein
perhaps you think it's a coincidence
that a ship all the way from North Korea
approaching the coast of Yemen was
recently stopped boarded and searched by
a Spanish vessel and discovered to
having it sold an elaborately concealed
cargo Scud missiles Yemen doesn't want
Scud missiles for anything where do you
think the end-use certificate of this
Scud missiles was going what is North
Korea got to sell at the moment only one
thing it's only got to sell plutonium
could be saddam hussein thought it by
the forces of regime change i will
insist from having a nuclear program
will buy one off the shelf that's a
thought even more frightening and much
more real than the equally not equally
but the considerably alarming scenario
mentioned by professor ignosi of now i
wouldn't be standing here today if i
hadn't been able to say as I did in
opening but I've been against this
policy of coddling that I was saying for
a long time I've been for regime change
longer than George Bush and I remain for
it if he was against it seems to me
unworthy of Mark Donohue to say we used
to have a bad policy Robert Scheer
echoes him glibly you clap as if a point
had been made I'm in favor of the policy
having changed I didn't think it was a
good thing when the when the US had
Saddam Hussein as a client I think it's
better it wants to get rid of him shall
I say that again slowly for anyone's
benefit is it not self is it not
self-evident is it not said it can it
not be easily demonstrated at a rate
that George Bush Senior had a different
policy he still does so does Brent
Scowcroft so does Lawrence Eagle burger
so there's Norman Schwarzkopf all those
people still think the 91 policy in the
earlier ones were correct and defensible
they still think so
: Powell I don't think has really
changed his mind something's changed it
lately but not that and the only person
I know in the administration who said
they were wrong before and they're right
now is the vice president it's it's
frivolous to say we used to be bad so
nothing we possibly could ever do was
any good this has been a long struggle
to get this argument underway and I
think it's I really think it's
depressing that people will
we will applaud the easiest and most
sarcastic attempted ironies of such a
serious project thank you
mark dinner it's clear that we have
major differences here you have no idea
regarding not simply the level of the
threat to the United States but the
possibility of dealing with it through
ways other than war the points to be
made about the events of the late 1980s
are to be made because those are the
events on which the administration has
made its case for war Bob Scheer is
perfectly right in saying nothing
recently has happened the crisis over
Iraq what is the crisis over Iraq
have we been attacked of course the Bush
administration would say yes September
11th and sotto voce actually Iraq was
responsible for that and they've this
has been a very politically lucrative
strategy for them but the fact is when
they're pointing at events that Saddam
Hussein is responsible for that should
make us want to attack invade and occupy
Iraq they point to events 15 years ago
this should cause us to be skeptical it
should cause us to look at Iraq and try
to understand what kind of threat it
does pose and how that threat can be
dealt with and it should cause us to
look at the Bush administration and try
to ask ourselves why is it doing what
it's doing now
I agree with Michael Ignatieff that
containment is difficult I agree with
him on that when a megalomania maniacal
dictator gets nuclear weapons this is
very threatening
I mean think for a moment if Stalin had
gotten nuclear weapons oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Stalin did get nuclear weapons the
United States followed for a
half-century a policy of patient
containment and it won and there was no
war and one could argue that it would
have been enormous ly bracing for the
forces of freedom to attack the Soviet
Union remove that immediate threat
remove the weapons of mass destruction
and liberate the Soviet people indeed
people did make that argument in the
early 50s Curtis LeMay Douglas MacArthur
others they were obsessed with the idea
of rollback President Eisenhower decided
in 1956 that the United States would not
follow this policy and the Hungarian
Revolution was crushed as a result these
are terrible events but the United
States must make a decision based on its
national interest on the threats facing
it and on its role in the world we
haven't talked enough I think tonight
about the effects this policy has had on
our alliances on our standing in the
world
and we haven't spoken enough I think of
the risks that a war will pose to the
political future of the Middle East and
to terrorism on America's streets
members of al Qaeda will never be
convinced to love the United States but
the political dynamic that al Qaeda is
struggling to put into place is being
actively advanced by the bush
administration that political dynamic
envisions a war of Islamists against the
West it envisions an attack on regimes
friendly to the United States such as
those in Cairo and Saudi Arabia
overthrowing theirs regimes and
replacing them with Islamist ones it
will benefit greatly from this policy we
will make no one love us it's true but
we will make a lot of people who matter
hate us this was the process set and
trained by 9/11 now should we make
policy based on our what we fear of al
Qaeda should we let them dominate our
policy absolutely not should we act
intelligently with an eye toward the
politics of this region I would argue
yes and I would put alongside or on top
of the list of risks that Michael
Ignatieff set out before you the risk
that you will start a politics of
anti-americanism and a wave of
repression throughout the Middle East as
a result of this invasion we say we are
doing it to advance democracy already in
Jordan already in Egypt security forces
are making their arrests they're making
their arrests and anticipation of
uprisings or at least demonstrations
that they believe will accompany this
war this will not lead to greater
democracy it will lead to greater
repression it will lead to forcing
opposition into the basement and when it
is forced into the basement
it comes out in noxious forms as we've
seen with al-qaeda the Islamist movement
that al-qaeda represents was on the
downturn the dramatic downturn before
September 11th it was on the downturn in
Algeria in Chechnya in Bosnia all of the
battles of the 90s had ended in defeat
al-qaeda cannot defeat the United States
but the United States I would argue can
defeat the United States by an by
unleashing a war that indeed could be a
72-hour wonder it's possible or it could
drag on it could kill only 10000 or
50,000 as the Gulf War did by the way
and that would be a good war 50,000 dead
no problem
or it could kill many more we don't know
that nobody on this stage can predict it
but that uncertainty to me belongs on
that list of risks very prominently on
that list of risks
now Michael Ignatieff talked about the
difficulty of containment I would argue
that there is a possibility for a deal
here in which inspectors can be
bolstered a longer deadline can be set
out benchmarks can be placed a
declaratory policy put in place in which
any sites suspicious that are not being
open to inspectors can be struck from
the air and a war crimes tribunal
started modeled on the hague to try the
iraqi regime all of this is quite
possible two-thirds of Iraqi territory
is covered by no-fly zones the rest is
crawling with inspectors the idea that
they represent an immediate threat to
the United States is ridiculous
but we we represent an immediate threat
to the United States
and now to Michael Ignatieff I wanted to
pick up a couple of points one of them
raised by Robert Scheer and I invite him
to correct me if I heard him wrong or
misunderstood what he was saying but he
was saying the option is between war and
waiting for four months I mean that is
and then that would fit in with what
Mark tenner was saying which is the
alternative is between war now and an
enhanced and strengthened inspection
regime along the lines proposed by other
governments I think my difficulty with
that is simply I don't believe that a
coercive inspections regime is credible
for one second and can be maintained
with for one second without precisely
the threat of the use of force which the
other people on the Security Council
have threatened to veto under any
circumstances the the hard reality the
painful reality is that I would not be
in favor of military action if I
believed that the Security Council was
prepared to go through with a coercive
and intrusive inspections program that
would deliver the results that you claim
I simply think that we have got where we
are and got some forms of minimal
notional compliance simply because the
United States has stepped up to the line
with a quarter a quarter of a million
troops and it's it seems to me that the
wait for four months argument is only
credible if Jacques Chirac had said had
not said what he said which is I'm going
to veto this under any circumstances you
can't this seems to me an exercise in
bad faith in the sense that you can't
have both of these propositions at once
and be credible we have been here before
we have had a chorus of inspections
regime that was slowly taken apart not
because there was any lack on the part
the previous inspections regime to be
coercive and intrusive as the as mark
and Robert are suggesting but simply
because the Security Council simply
didn't want to threaten or deploy force
to make it work I mean what one has to
think through is whether there really is
a credible sustainable alternative here
which will deliver what we want I don't
see it
I also think that moving on to the
second issue that has been much
discussed particularly by Marcus the
dismissal of the threat and a point made
about Stalin and containment
I think the Stalin argument has merit
but it has a problem which is that it
relates to a world which is vanished I
don't think that we are in that world
anymore we're in a world where the
illicit transfer of lethal technologies
the illicit transfer of technologies
that can cause mass casualty harms right
here is the world we're living in we can
deter States we can interdict shipments
but we've now reached the world where it
seems to me we're dealing with
terrorists who are under turrible and
the key issue is to prevent them from
acquiring capabilities that can you know
destroy the city of Los Angeles tor kill
everybody in this room and this seems to
me to be a fundamentally different
reality than the one that we faced when
we were dealing with state to state
deterrence in the Cold War the final
point I would make is that I hear in
both Roberts and Marx comments of a kind
of dirty hands argument there was
applause when Mark said or when Robert
said
we can't really trust the Americans to
do the right thing in this case because
in previous instances they have been
aligned and compromised immoral illicit
ways with this regime with a Saddam
regime and other regimes and I think
that's the kind of what's called a dirty
hands argument no one can do anything
clean if their hands have ever been
dirty and I find that an example of a
kind of enfeebling moral perfectionism
that is to say
you must mean relative you must be
relativism you must be then feeling
moral relativism there was nothing
perfectionist in that argument no no it
is perfectionist in the sense that it it
says you can only do good actions if
your hands are perfectly clean at all
times that's what I mean by corrosion
it's not the argument as stated it was
written well
many good actions consequential actions
are accomplished in this world by people
with dubious records as I said when I
concluded my opening remarks you're not
required if you believe that war is
regretfully the only option that's
actually real and credible here you're
not required to believe that the United
States is the last best hope of mankind
you're not required to forget the very
pertinent points that mark and Robert
have made about the ghastly mistakes of
American foreign policy in this room in
this region over the last thirty years
you are asked to decide what we do now
what are our options now what credible
options are available now and with due
respect to both Robert and and Mark what
I I just do not hear a credible
deliverable strategy because the will
the intention the desire which you
clearly feel about this I'm not
questioning your intentions I'm not
questioning your desire to restrict
control dismantle this infernal regime
of weapons of mass destruction I am
saying that the strategic partners of
the United States will not pull the
trigger and that's a challenge that you
have to provide an answer to because
otherwise there simply is no other way
to take these weapons away
Robert Scheer first of all I employ
people not to applaud anything I might
say because yeah it will prove that my
argument is invalid and in general this
is actually the tactic that's been used
to dismiss public opinion throughout the
world the people who demonstrate the
largest demonstration in history of
Berlin since the Second World War
they're dismissed is what naive pacifist
the French who get a large number of 9s
against the war who who were after all a
number of whom fought family support in
Algeria and Vietnam lost quite a few in
the first world war experience bombings
in their country maybe they're speaking
out of the experience of imperialism in
opposing such a course of action and
Christopher Hitchens a native country
here we have the example of Tony Blair
who claims to be again interested in
exploiting democracy and it's totally
indifferent to the feelings of 80
percent of his public the the argument
is that the true test of leadership is
being indifferent to the public in a
democratic society otherwise you're a
wimp let me straighten up a few things
here first of all I am for action I
supported it in my column
Mavis Leno and the feminist majority and
ultimately Bill Clinton when they said
that we had a responsibility to remove
the monsters of our creation to Taliban
which not fifteen years before or forty
years before or five years before but in
that moment were oppressing the majority
of their population I defended the
attack on the Taliban quite apart from
al Qaeda because I said we put these
people in power and we trained them
secondly once they were harboring
al-qaeda and once these people attacked
our embassies clearly we had a right to
go after him so it is a false argument
and if he's inspector
is informed presumably by our
intelligence agencies find these weapons
of mass destruction that are threatening
find some evidence that any of this is
being given to terrorists I am in favor
of action and for shutting them down we
bomb Iraq all the time don't tell me
that our hundred billion dollar a year
observation system cannot find the
buildings where stuff is being produced
and our planes can't take it out it's
just not true no so that is I think a
false argument and let me say this thing
about North Korea slipping north Korea
has actively worked with Pakistan
that's how Pakistan Karthi our nuclear
option it's very frightening as you well
know you want to this is a country which
Christopher always talks about religion
as being the I guess what the was the
thing Mark said opium the people and it
is more dangerous he thinks it's the
craft of the people the fact is that
Pakistan which has these weapons which
gotten through cooperation with Korea
just yesterday was taken off are finally
off our sanctions list finally not to be
punished in any way for a having this
dictatorship which we were upset at but
one point we don't care about democracy
in Pakistan and in fact one of the great
ironies it is what if the Muslim
majority comes to power or threatened to
come to power as in Algeria and wants to
do all these terrible things then will
suddenly won't believe in democracy
anymore
but in the case of Pakistan where you
have active nuclear force what about
Iran just in the last two weeks we found
that Iran the one country that will most
immediately benefit from the destruction
of Iraq is Iran clearly three times the
population historical enemy has this
Shiite population that might be
sympathetic crossed the border Iran and
thanks very proudly that they're
developing nuclear weapons Iran I would
point out to you was one of the
countries we were once very frightened
of however I would also point out to you
and the reason I do think the dirty
hands I don't know quite all the way
with Christopher and think that Henry
Kissinger should be hung or something
but I do think dirty hands matter and
the fact that Elliott Abrams is now in
charge of the Mideast at the National
Security Council does matter when he's
the guy who did the trade with Iran and
the Contras how can it not matter and by
the way just to put this argument to
rest about the Jewish conspiracy which
was I think effectively exposed by sy
Hersh in The New Yorker the problem with
some of the Jewish people in this
ministration is not that they're
pro-israel is that they are against arms
control richard perle was the guy a
treasure vic who was opposed to Ronald
Reagan making a deal with Gorbachev
Richard Perle has been opposed to every
arms control agreement they have never
believed in any inspection regime that's
what we're talking about and if you
throw in Elliott Abrams but by the way
it's hardly Jewish people Rumsfeld who
we're going to now trust is the guy who
in 1984 after the UN concluded that Iraq
had used chemical weapons went to Sodom
Hussein and said there's no problem here
we're going to recognize you
we're gonna have relations we're gonna
give you aid and everything that was
Donald Rumsfeld so the question of dirty
hands let me say is not that people
cannot be redeemed obviously they can
the problem is we're fierce what were
they what motives were they acting out
of before now I know Dennis Kucinich got
beat over the head and no one is gonna
ever mention the word that he used oil
okay oil oil you're not allowed to talk
about it well let me tell you we didn't
go to war with Iraq over human rights
when it invaded Kuwait one of the human
rights we were defending in Kuwait the
right of the Emir to have 70 virgins
each week you know we went to war
because we cared about the oil you know
that's why we went to war
and if you have this idea historically
that for the United States to now move
in to the second most important source
of oil in the world and take over and
run it through an American general if
that does not smack of imperialism I
don't know what does and that's why
people are suspicious it seems to me the
question is not a distrust of America
the American people I am amazed at how
many Americans see through this war we
don't have a draft they've been lied to
systematically they were frightened by
September 11th and yet we have a large
number of Americans close to a majority
they're opposed to this part I I loved
this country
I loved Americans it's the people who
act as maniacs in the name of America
that I'm afraid of
we might follow up his remarks with some
questions in which we'll try to be equal
opportunity provocateur but let's carry
on with the question the argument that
Robert Scheer has has initiated and
let's turn to well perhaps both
Christopher Hitchens and Michael
Ignatieff each in their own way can
perhaps answer for a cynic who might ask
how is it mr. Hitchens you a scourge of
Henry Kissinger deeply skeptical of his
motives and intentions
why now have you placed your faith in
the ability of such Kissinger wannabes
as Paul Wolfowitz and Richard Perle and
Dick Cheney and Rumsfeld what gives you
such confidence that they will be able
to make the world safe for democracy
when they have evinced critics would
argue such contempt for it at home
I should first say that I don't seek the
execution of Henry Kissinger I'm an
author really opposed to capital
punishment but I do think I do think he
should be charged with crimes against
humanity war crimes and I think if I
think if charge would would be convicted
what Marx said about religion by the way
was that it was the heart of the
heartless world the sigh of the
oppressed preacher the spirit of the
spiritless situation an opiate for the
people and that criticism had plucked
the flowers from a chain not so that men
could wear the chain without consolation
but so that they could break a chain and
call the Living flower which I think is
much better polish now on the question
of Henry Kissinger and Rael politique as
it worked well perhaps it's escaped the
attention of many people that every
member of kissing the associates known
to me including its chairman is against
this war and against the regime change
policy and always has been and that the
Saudi Arabian a regime which I think has
a pretty oleaginous influence in
Washington is against the regime change
policy - and is a very odd way for the
oil companies to be behaving in the oil
lobby to be carrying on I'm not one of
those who thinks that oil can't be
mentioned as if it was some kind of
ghastly bodily secretions that was too
indecent to discuss and I don't think no
I don't think it's a prudent policy to
allow 9% of the world's energy resources
to be at the mercy of a man who blew up
the Kuwaiti oil fields if you remember
while he was leaving I'm sorry he didn't
democratize Kuwait enough I'm sorry we
didn't either but the Kuwaitis are a lot
better off for his departure ladies and
gentlemen and it's silly to say they are
not ottoman pliers
he blew those oil fields up when he'd
been warned not to and he blew them up
when the act of vandalism could do him
no good and he flooded the Gulf with
burning oil and this is the man who's
believed to understand deterrence and
containment no it's just as true to say
of the earlier policy of successive
administration's of backing Saddam
Hussein
helping him in the Gulf War helping to
him to reflagged
tankers and generally arming and
covering up for him that was blood for
oil when the United States was on his
side and allowing him to slaughter
Iraqis and Kurds and invade other
countries that was blood for oil just as
much so I'm glad to have Robert shears
admission that it can be true early it
seems in his case for Afghanistan it can
be true that earlier crimes and blunders
give you an extra responsibility they
mean you have to do something to repair
the crimes and blunders that you
committed and one of my reasons for
supporting this policy is precisely
because it it's a responsibility we've
inherited for having got it's so wrong
so long and for oil okay nobody
interested in safeguarding oil wants to
do it by war it's much easier to do it
by client state or proxy regime here
will be my defense then if more wolf
with wolf which has been arguing since
78 that it is unwise for the United
States to rely on client regimes he
began this argument as a critique of the
Shah
he made it as an as a critique of Saddam
Hussein later of Ferdinand Marcos still
later when he was ambassador in the
Philippines of the super hot air regimes
had bases at this price are not worth
having if you have an American presence
in a country you need a dictatorship to
guarantee the presence then you'll lose
both on you and say you should and that
democratization movement that began with
the overthrow of Marcos and went into
South Korea and and into Taiwan and then
into Tiananmen Square and then later
into Eastern Europe is one of the great
political events of my lifetime as far
as I can see he's been I can only speak
for him on the right side of all of that
and you may notice that Henry Kissinger
was on the other side each time pro
Saudi Pro Chinese Communist Party probe
dictatorship in South Korea and even
considering the revolutions in Eastern
Europe to be destabilizing this is
actually a policy that can be defended
almost as one that is quixotic people
say it's risky
all right then I'll admit it that's part
of what I like about it it does take the
risk that democracy and self-government
is both more desirable and more stable
and more defensible than 10 dictatorship
Boxey rule I think it can be
consistently argued now just one thing
on this thing I've been taunted about
about allies I I can't really tell you
why it is that if ninety percent of
people disagree with me I would still
hold the position I do I'll just let you
guess if I'm told will use may say that
when I know ten other people who don't
I'm not impressed how does that affect
the argument doesn't affect it at all
but I know that the same people would
have been telling me until recently were
in fact telling me she recently ah look
who supports the policy Turkey supports
it now it doesn't Saudi Arabia never did
many of the regional despotisms didn't
want it for obvious obvious reasons I
would say the less the better the fewer
the better there is a policy of
unilateralism pursued by the government
of France which built Saddam Hussein a
nuclear reactor knowing what he wanted
it for which is entirely oil driven
which intervenes colonial II in Africa
with force at any time that's choosing
and which tests nuclear weapons in the
South Pacific not caring about the
wishes of the neighboring countries or
their inhabitants one day and who's a
president and whose president had to run
for office to stay out of jail and
preserve his immunity on very serious
charges of corruption which include the
charges of a long relationship with the
Iraqi Baath Party I can say no more than
that mr. shurok has never refused to
briber mr. Saddam Hussein has never
failed to offer one I know no more than
that for now but I'm waiting I'm holding
out for the day that I see the word
unilateral in the New York Times next to
the word French and then I'll be more
impressed by the it seems to me that
there's no discredit at all in the in
the enmity the United States has found
for itself on this it rather advanced to
the credit of the president and his
policy thank you
a two-part question for Michael
Ignatieff one both rhetorical one you
decry the specter of the illicit
transfer of lethal technology to third
parties other countries brigands of one
kind or another but doesn't it strike
you as surpassingly paradoxical that the
single most devastating terrorist attack
on this country to date was committed by
men who bought their weapons of mass
destruction from Home Depot box cutters
isn't this Spectre that we are now going
to war or seem to be about to go to war
to prevent doesn't it seem to you
misplaced when at least by one measure
the real weapons are here at home that's
one part of it the second part is you
have paint a very rosy a picture of a of
a allied well I use the word advisedly
an American British victory in Iraq of
the prosperity that will be the
democracy of a freed Iraq so that they
may use their oil money as you put it
for the rehabilitation of their roads
schools and hospitals but doesn't it
give you pause when in the largest
democracy of the world it has used so
little of its prosperity to do the very
same thing
as to question 1 look nobody thinks that
if you replace the Saddam regime that
that eliminates threats to the United
States that's just not a credible
proposition it's obvious that low-tech
does much damage on September 11th but
we need to think seriously about the
possibility of a mass casualty
bioterrorist attack it is the case that
the sources of those awful weapons could
come from a lot of other places than
Saddam's regime
I quite concede that point but he's one
source and he's the source with
intention he's the source he's a he's a
source with purpose he's a source with a
motive and he's a powerful ruler of an
oil-producing State I'm not I'm simply
saying that the public policy issue that
citizens in this room have to think
about is everybody's one side of this
house is saying the threats very low and
I'm saying the threat is maybe 5% but
I'm not happy about 5% I'm not happy
about 3% if we're talking about mass
casualty terrorism devastating a city
like Los Angeles we've got to rethink
the issue of what threat here is too
much threat nobody on this side of the
house is saying that if you take out
Saddam these threats are eliminated
these threats continue and one of the
most difficult pub sorry
I mean an answer to that question I
think Saddam Hussein belongs in a very
exclusive club all of his own thanks
very much I have no desire to do this
except under the most pressing necessity
the case I'm making this this is a
pressing necessity not the prelude to a
march around the world second on the
question of an after Iraq scenario I
didn't paint a rosy picture I painted a
picture full of risk and hazard any
responsible person looking at this
post-war world in Iraq has to be honest
about the difficulties deep divisions in
the country possibilities of conflict
absence of a democratic tradition a
police tyranny and a police terror that
has rooted right into the guts and heart
and soul of 25 million people so that
they're afraid even to dream a free
dream right so nobody in their right
minds thinks any transition is going to
be easy I've been I've walked the ground
however in Afghanistan I've walked the
ground in Kosovo I've walked the ground
in Bosnia the American investment of
force and power in those three regions
has made lives better for ordinary human
beings not perfect not wonderful not as
nice as Los Angeles but a hell of a lot
better than what was there before
America used military force
so nobody's spinning out rosy scenarios
I just you know point out that when when
Robert was saying and again we don't
want to polarize this falsely nobody on
this side of the argument is saying
you're against strong measures you don't
care about Saddam you Europe prepared to
appease him that's never been my
position with either of your views and
it's perfectly obvious to me that Robert
wants to take strong and resolute
measures in respect of Saddam but what
he said for example was we should bomb
him from the air we should you know take
tough measures in in the autumn but you
know the hard reality of that is that
that's a certain kind of toughness that
still leaves 25 million people in jail
right it's a it's a form of toughness
that does some of the job but in my
judgment not all of the job
and let me turn to you mark and you may
of course answer this in any way you
wish what about the argument which has
been put very forcefully by both Messrs
Hitchens and Ignatieff that precisely
because the United States in the past
did a great deal to support the Balthus
party into power precisely because it
did a lot to coddle and turn a blind eye
to the depredations that Saddam Hussein
unleashed against his own people that
all the more reason that we owe a blood
death to the Iraqi people which we
cannot in good conscience walk away from
and that to define our national
interests so selfishly as to exclude the
25 million people who are unable to
liberate themselves would be an ignoble
thing and it's a risk that we ought to
take to remain true to ourselves as a
people who ought to be able to hold up
their heads in the world arena despite
what others fear might be unleashed and
that this is indeed a good and noble
cause well that was very eloquently
stated you know : powell said during
Bosnia when he was chairman the Joint
Chiefs and he didn't want to intervene
that when he heard the word surgical
strike he headed for his bunker I must
say that when I hear moralism mixed with
foreign affairs from high officials I
had from my bunker
I am NOT trying to make the dirty hands
argument here the United States can act
for good in the world
I supported intervention in Bosnia I
wished it had happened much much much
earlier than it did after everybody was
dead
I am not making a dirty hands argument
I'm making an unclouded Minds argument
that is I mean I'm gratified frankly
that we've talked about the past so nice
so much on this panel tonight I'm a
great fan of the past particularly the
recent past because I think it leads us
to look at things as they are and that's
what I'm pleading with this audience to
do I think Michael Ignatieff sentiments
are very noble I'm sympathetic to many
of them but I think by his own arguments
the calculus of risks he makes is not
reasonable he said a moment ago that 5%
if I there's 5% a risk of Saddam giving
chemical weapons or biological weapons
to terrorists that's too much
therefore we should occupy invade attack
occupy Iraq I would ask him what
percentage risk does he think there is
if we attack Iraq and occupy it that is
is the risk reduced by fighting a war in
which he has absolutely no incentive to
contain himself I think the notion that
Saddam Hussein is not containable is
rubbish in 1990 he had weapons of mass
destruction that is he had chemical
weapons certainly he was told and no
uncertain terms by James Baker among
others that use of these weapons would
bring the most severe consequences he
didn't use them he used them against the
Iranians who by the way used them back
and in their turn so the notion that he
can't be contained and deterred is
completely unsupported or that he's
erratic we knew in advance about the
attack on Iran we knew about
month three weeks to a month in advance
about the invasion of Kuwait he did it
very slowly so our intelligence
satellites could see the disposition of
forces and we essentially perhaps
stupidly gave him a green light in a
fact or what he took to be a green light
so this notion of this insane dictator
who's just doing whatever he wants and
who you know will ravage the world I
think is misplaced I don't think history
bears it out we've said a word here
tonight about North Korea North Korea
has two nuclear weapons by the end of
the summer it will have eight the single
thing this administration has achieved
with respect to North Korea is taken
from a regime that had to to taking it
to a regime that will soon have eight
and more and the administration in the
general policy of letting the Iraq tail
wag the world dog is saying you know
what we're not going to pay attention to
this until Iraq is done quote-unquote
now you want to talk about irresponsible
policies that's an irresponsible policy
one should add by the way that
Christopher's argument that our that
North Korea
demonstrates the necessity of attacking
invading and occupying Iraq has a number
of vital flaws
North Korea's deter deters us from
attacking it by its conventional forces
it can level Seoul in a matter of hours
it's a fact of geography and a fact of
conventional armaments we have to deal
with the nuclear question in North Korea
and we will do it eventually
diplomatically the question is how
terrible that deal for eventually there
will be a deal how terrible that deal
will be and every day the prospective
deal gets worse
finally Michaels point about the
palestinian-israeli peace settlement and
its necessity for US policy I agree with
him wholeheartedly on this point I would
point out that George Bush only
yesterday finally announced after saying
he would not a so called roadmap for
peace which other nations have been
pushing him to do he did it at the
instance of Tony Blair to try to protect
him domestically and he did it in
essentially pulling the rug out from the
entire premise of this so-called
roadblock that as he said it was a basis
for discussions the idea that this
government which has supported our Elser
own and everything he's done which has
given him no incentive to stop
settlement activity or to expand them
will at some point force Cerrone to do
this
I think beggars reality and beggars what
we see in front of us
Robert Scheer it's probably a fool's
mission to look for consistency in
foreign policy as it is in much of the
rest of life particularly in moral terms
but why shouldn't the United States seek
to unseat a sawdust Caesar who has
certainly in the past and may yet in the
future deploy terrible weapons not only
against his own people but others as
well not because our ability to do so is
constrained elsewhere in the world but
because as a matter of opportunity we
can and we ought to do so because it's
the right thing to do well I guess I
don't believe it is the right thing to
do in general to make other people's
history for them and I think Marx who
said the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
it seems to me the irony of the of the
whole Cold War period is that we ended
up being on the side of his many
horrible regimes as the Communists did
even though our motives were clearly
superior we supported as many
dictatorships we oppressed as many
people so I am very wary of intervention
except in extreme situations where you
can show genocide
the reason I mention this thing about
going against Al Hussein if you could
actually show evidence which our CIA
says doesn't exist that was their first
report if you could show any evidence at
all of where other stuff is made of
they're lying to the inspectors but in
fact what we're objecting to now it
seems is an inspection process that is
working that is vigorous that is getting
rid of weapons that is telling us what's
going on there and this is why in the
world would we be against knowledge
that's what I don't understand we have
satellites we have all sorts of spy
intercepts if we know where these
weapons are why don't we tell Hans
that's what I don't understand why are
we it seems to me actually criminal to
hold back this information now we're
where we really have a disagreement here
is my green light just seven minutes or
not but we have our real disagreement it
seems to me is where the history began
with September 11th and it went off
again Christopher you don't have to be
too alarmed but where this argument
history and terrorism began was
September 11th is absolutely nonsense
first of all as was pointed out the
September 11th attack did not involve
weapons of mass destruction and that
line about Home Depot was taken from one
of my columns was someone but you know
there's been terror in fact Bulgaria
which is one of our supporters now no
one's bothered to ask the Bulgarians did
they are they the ones who tried to kill
the Pope remember that one
well garyun plot against the Pope and we
used to think of these now we think of
the Communists as stable reasonable
people that you could deal with
containment that's not what I remember I
remember Tom Dooley and the stories of
the bloody rampage of the Vietnamese
against Catholics and that's why we had
to intervene I remember the yellow horde
the Chinese ants that were going to come
sweeping down the the horrible KGB
terrorists that were threatening
everyone in the world and we're behind
terror all over the world you know we've
reinvented history here now that salamu
saying is the first guy to come along or
may support terror the fact is Pakistan
supported the Taliban Pakistan supported
al Qaeda you know they helped them they
aided them after they blew up our
embassy so this idea that somehow we
have this totally new phenomena is to my
mind false and what I would suggest take
the case of Qaddafi in Libya whoever
even talks about Qaddafi anymore
without it wasn't to answer your
question Steve isn't he someone we
should have taken out but we didn't take
him out and nobody ever talks about
Gaddafi anymore and we didn't take
Castro out and yes you could say those
people live in jail but you know you
could have said that about the Russians
right 200 million people living and what
a million people in China but you know
what history has a way of being made by
people other than Wolfowitz and
Kissinger and one of one of the great
weapons in that is normalcy and trade
and contact and not turning people into
the devil and not saying that you won't
talk and what happened with North Korea
alright we had an imperfect relationship
under Clinton but we were talking to
them why can't we follow South Korea's
lead and deal with North Korea they've
said give us a promising you're not
going to attack us
why is that such a hard promise to give
I don't understand that well now have
two minutes of rebuttal from each of the
panelists and a bit of some ring up Wow
on the terror connection I'd better be
quick then do a thought experiment on
the 12th of September 2001 Saddam
Hussein calls in his chief of
intelligence says do you know anything
about this guys who did this yesterday
no mr. president never heard of them
don't know a thing about it the guy
wouldn't live out the day if that was
his answer
the Oh Bernie Dahl organization.i which
used to be as synonymous with terror as
bin Laden is now was headquartered in
Baghdad I went to interview album you
tell there it wasn't hard to do he had a
villa he had a phone number he was an
extension a political extension of the
Baath Party of the Iraqi state Iraq
openly boasts of its support for the
suicide murderers in Palestine and it
has sheltered al Qaeda members numbers
of them on its territory since September
the 11th whereas the Pakistanis and the
Saudis have ceased to do so and are in
any case more or less under American
scrutiny so the double standard thing
there simply doesn't work yes Iraq has
always been an Arsenal and backer of
international gangsterism and remains so
to doubt this is foolish there is
something inherently unstable about
dictatorship
inherently aggressive about it now I
really don't feel that anything that's
been said in reply to that proposition
couldn't can can alter that fact the the
plain fact of the matter is that Iraq
and North Korea are different they are
exorbitant totalitarian regimes they're
not just other bad guys people who make
that comparison don't know anything
about the sort of regime that that
exists there the the endless slavery and
coercion and yet they say why don't we
go round and destroy all the other bad
guys while we're about it and they know
perfectly well that if that was the
United States policy which it isn't they
would describe it as imperialist
overreaching and quixotic so I really
think be serious ok get real mark dinner
I would argue here tonight for a foreign
policy that is not based on fear
based on as in 1919 as in 1945 250 we
are living in a period in which our
approach to the world is being redefined
at present the symbol of that
redefinition is President Bush floating
on his island in the Atlantic
accompanied only by Prime Minister
Astana and Prime Minister Blair the
question is whether the United States
can exert power in the world without
alienating the rest of it this
administration has participated over the
last few months in a fascinating
experiment in the limits of power
Michael said that there is no deal to be
made on the Security Council I think
that's wrong
I think the French indeed can be brought
around to promise the use of force given
a reasonable deadline given reasonable
benchmarks and given a reasonable policy
between now and then I think that's
possible and one cannot argue it's
impossible because the United States has
not tried it one should also say as a
comment on deterrence in Saddam Hussein
that in order for a policy of arms
inspection and disarmament under
international auspices to work the Iraqi
regime must be assured that if it
disarms it will not be attacked invaded
and occupied anyway and that has never
been the case that has never been the
case I'd say to all of you tonight that
if indeed we go to war very soon as
looks quite possible and perhaps looks
quite probable this will not be over
this will not be over one has to remain
interested vigilant concerned and
involved and I thank all of you for
coming because this struggle about the
soul of this country is nowhere near
over I have to close though my red light
is on with a quote from John Quincy
Adams 1821 he told America to go not
abroad in
search of monsters to destroy but his
reasoning was not about the inherent
difficulty of that or at least not only
he said that if America did go abroad in
search of monsters to destroy it would
become the dictated tris of the world
but would no longer be the ruler of her
own spirit I ask all of you in the hall
tonight to keep that in mind because
that threat if war comes if it doesn't
however bloody it is however quickly it
goes that will remain the question for
all of us
Michael gotcha picking up on what Mark
Danner says I think first of all that a
concerted attempt over 12 years has been
made to develop to develop a
international consensus to disarm Saddam
by force I think it's just not true to
say that diplomacy has not been tried I
think what's happened here is that the
French the Russians and the Chinese will
not go where the United States feels
it's in its national interest to go I
don't I think there have been obvious
failings in the diplomacy of the Bush
administration but it takes two to tango
here and I think mark is sorely
underestimated the basic unwillingness
of the other powers in this network to
actually back what they say with the
liberal deliverable and credible threats
because I think deliverable and credible
threats are the only things that got any
progress in this matter
mark also raised the issue of John
Quincy Adams a call to watch out about
the dangers of slaying monsters abroad
I'm very hesitant I share his worries
about moralism in foreign affairs but I
would point out that this country has
slain some monsters and the world is
immensely better because it did so yeah
Milosevic of Serbia is in The Hague a
monster who was slain by the exercise of
American power
the Serbs removed Milosevic well if you
if
Oh Cassius if you don't casuistry there
are limited cases in which the United
States I think should go abroad to slay
monsters and it can do so without losing
its soul as a republic at home Robert
Scheer let me first say there's no
question that we have the power the
soviets had the power that you know the
french had the power they've been
powerful regimes before there's no
reason to assume this power it will be
used in a wise way and let me give you a
good example when i would happen to be
in egypt in Israel at the time of the
six-day war and I remember Marsh Dayan
saying come back in ten years in the
Soviet era dice and he and every reason
to say that sincerely first of all he
knew Arabic he knew the country
he knew the miserable conditions under
which Palestinians had lived in Gaza and
and had lived in under the Egyptians and
had lived in the West Bank under
Jordanians and he thought indoor
plumbing democracy secular whatever he
was sincere about it and we see the
result people want to make their own
history their history is complex their
religions are complex nationalism is
complex and what I think the French the
Germans you know the Chinese the
Russians the Chileans and all the others
are saying to us is you guys led by a
president who never even bothered to use
his American Express card to visit us
who never cared about us who has
transferred your enormous angst and
feeling about terrorism and weapons of
mass destruction has lied to the
American people will not lie to us and
get away with it
and I think that's an important
restraint
instead of demeaning the United Nations
I think this is the first time in the
history of the United Nations that it is
acting as the organization that was
intended to be
this is this is not a case of the Soviet
Union saying yet this is a case of
democratic societies like France and
Germany saying to us we love America and
for that reason we're here to tell you
you're wrong and you're making a very
big mistake as one can readily hear and
one can readily see this is a debate
that has no end and we'll never have any
end so long as citizens debate whether a
nation ought to have a moral mission in
the world in a real politic world in
which monsters are loose and evil is
there and good needs to be done and
people need to decide and debate amongst
themselves where their true interests
lie the Los Angeles Times in the Los
Angeles Institute for Humanities and the
UC Berkeley Graduate School of
Journalism as well as all the other
co-sponsors thank all of you in this
theater The Wiltern for coming tonight
and we thank all of you at c-span who
are tuning in tonight we're listening to
this broadcast and we thank KCRW 89.9 FM
for recording it and airing it on monday
between 2:00 and 4:00 thank you and good
night